字幕: Rinako Otsuka
校正: Ayana Ishiyama
こんにちは！
荻田と申します
よろしくお願いします
私 北極冒険家という
肩書きで生きているんですけども
まあその名の通り北極で冒険をしています
冒険て どういうことかというと
この映像に今 映っていると思うんですけども
自分で荷物を引いて 自分の力で歩くという
エクスペディションを行っているんですね
北極点の無補給単独徒歩
という今挑戦を 2012年から
挑戦しています
どういうことかと言うとですね
北極点は分かりますよね
分かりますよね
地球の中心の軸ですけども
北極点まで 無補給単独徒歩というスタイル
自分の力で 無補給というのは
途中で 行程の途中で
外部からの物資補給を受けない
という意味なんですけども
無補給の 単独ですから 完全に一人
徒歩なので自分の足で
自力で歩いていくっていうことですね
カナダの最北端の岬をスタートして
北極点まで 800キロあるんですけども
その800キロを 海の上をずっと歩いていくんですね
北極海です
今この映っている写真も海の上なんですけど
北極海って意外と深いんですよ
水深が 北極点の付近だと
4000メートルくらいあるんですね
海の深さが
その表面が そうですね
2・3メートルくらいですか
凍っているだけなんです
表面だけですね
薄膜 みたいなものが浮いている程度の
氷でしかなくてですね
その上を歩いて行くんですね
海っていうのは 何でしょう
海流とか 風がありますので 流れるんですね
動くことによって お互いぶつかり合うと
このような 山のような 乱氷帯っていうんですけども
そういうものを作って 道なんか当然ないわけですね
そういう中を 自分の荷物を
100キロくらいのものをですね
50日くらいかかるんですけども
食糧なんかを積んだ荷物を 自分で引いて
進んでいくと　まあそういうことです
当然リスクもあってですね
白熊にテント揺らされたりですとかね
そういうこともありますし
過去二回 テントを白熊に
揺らされたりしたこともあるんですけども
誰もいないところで
自分のミスでテントの中で火を出して
両手を大やけどを負って 救助されたりとかっていう
経験も そして失敗も当然 あります
今まで2000年から
今年の３月４月も 北極点の挑戦をやって
今回 今年が二度目の挑戦です
北極点に関してはですね
北極圏 カナダ北極圏 グリーンランド
全部合わせると今まで13回 2000年から
通っています
まあそういう人間なんですね
多くの人は 「何でそんなことやるんですか？」と
ね （笑） まあ誰でも思いますよね
危ないでしょうと
危険なのに 死にそうな目に遭ってまで
なんでそんなことやるんですか
っていう風に聞くんですけども
こう言ったら 誤解を受けるかも
しれないんですけども
多分我々のような人間というのは
死にそうで大変だからこそ やるんですよね
大変じゃなかったら多分やらないんですよ
何か別に スリルが楽しいとか
そういうわけでもないですし
命を弄んでいるつもりもないですし
私死にたくはないので
絶対死にたくはないんですけど
ただ リスクがあるからこそ
それは冒険になり得るわけであって
まあ 「危険を冒す」 と書いて冒険ですから
危険が前提である そのリスクがあるから
どうやって それを越えていこうっていうことで
試行錯誤が生まれるわけですね
北極の探検というのは
古くは 紀元前くらいから 行われてきているんですけども
時代ごとにね
盛んな時期というのがあったんですけど
最後に盛んになった時期っていうのは
多分19世紀の
前半ぐらいだと思うんですけども
ナポレオン戦争でナポレオンが
フランス帝国が負けて
1815年かな
イギリス海軍っていうのが
フランスを一生懸命倒そうと思って
兵力をものすごい増強したわけですね
軍艦一生懸命いっぱい作って
軍隊を一生懸命強くして
でも敵がいなくなっちゃったんですね ある日
「ああどうしよう」と
若い将校たちが 「じゃあ俺たちの出世は
敵がいないんじゃ出世の機会もないぞ」と
「じゃあどうしよう」 ということで
長らく忘れられていたその北極の探検
というのに目を向けて
当時 イギリス領だったカナダの北部の方ですね
まだ地図が空白地帯で もしかしたら
イギリスから 太平洋の方に航路が
北西航路っていうんですけど
作れるかもしれない
というので たくさん軍艦を 送り込むわけですね
でもやっぱりこういう所ですから
たくさん人は死ぬわけですね
船はぼんぼん沈没するし
だんだんここは航路にも
使えないんじゃないかっていう風に
気付いて来るんですけども
まあその頃に面白いエピソードがあって
「何でそんなことやるのか」っていう
その理由のヒントになる
言葉を発した人がいてですね
ジョン・ロスっていう探検家がいるんですけれども
当時イギリスの国会に呼ばれたんですね
議員会に呼ばれて そのジョン・ロスが
その北西航路 新しい航路発見のために
そのイギリスの政府は一生懸命 お金も人も費やして
探検を行っているけども
「それにはどんな公共の利益が伴うのだ」 と
「北西航路の開拓ができたら
何か公共の利益になるのか？」って言ったら
そのジョン・ロスっていうのは
「全く何の利益にも繋がらないと私は信じている」と
要は 意味ないよ と言ったんですね
そのジョン・ロス本人も
その隊長として行ってるんですよ 何回も
「北西航路はどこだ」 って一生懸命
探しに行っている本人が
「いや 何の意味もないよ」って言ったんですよ
なんでそんな所行くんでしょうかと
そういう話っていっぱいあるんですよね
いっぱいあるんですけども
多分純粋に 行きたかったんだと思うんですよ
そのジョン・ロスも他の探検家も
見てみたいんですね
まだ地図の空白地で
そこがどうなっているかも分からないと
どんな世界があるんだろう
自分の手で その謎を解き明かしてみたい
自分の目で 一番初めに見てみたい
そういう純粋な思いだったんじゃないかな と
大義名分 というのは
国家としての大義名分 というのがある
でそれを実行するのはやはり 「個人」なんですね
個の集まりが隊になって で行くと
そういう情熱を持った探検家 というか
一人ひとりの情熱を持った
人間がいなければ組織としての探検も
ありえなかった ですね
じゃあ今の時代 そこから 100年 200年 くだって
今の2014年っていう時代は
私がこうやって北極を一人で歩くことに
どんな意味があるのかっていうと
おそらく その19世紀以上に
社会的意味は多分ないんですよね
私が北極歩いたら 世界が平和になるわけでもないですし
難病の子供の病気が治るわけでもなんでもなくて
じゃあなんで行くのか っていうことなんですけども
根底にあるのは
そのジョン・ロスの言葉もそうなんですけども
端的に言っちゃうと 「行きたいから」なんですね
私もその世界を見てみたいんですね
そして自分の力を試したい
当然過酷な世界ですから
そこに行くと 日常生活では感じられない
教訓というのがたくさん あるわけですね
我々日常を生きていると 私もそうですけど
まさか明日死ぬと思わないじゃないですか
でもいつか死ぬと
みんな分かっているじゃないですか
なんでしょう 理屈として
死は 何でしょう 概念でしかない というか
都市社会に生きていると
でもそんなことないですよね
明日 私死んでるかもしれないです
交通事故に遭ってね
その可能性は大いにあるんですけども
まさかそうなるとは思ってないんですけど
でもこういう北極 とかそういう世界に行くと
「死」 というものがリアルなんですよね
概念じゃないんですよ
「ここ」 にあるんですよね
明日自分が生きている という保証はなくて
ちょっとしたミスで 死ぬ可能性もありますし
そこにものすごく近づいてしまって
「ああヤバイ」 と思うこともあるんですよね
だからその何でしょう
「生と死 生きると死ぬ」っていうのは
「太陽と影」 みたいなもので
やはりどちらか一方が こうくっきりするには
もう片方が 必要なんですよね
やはりその死 というものが
目の前にあって それを自分で認識して自覚してるから
「ああ俺は今生きているんだな」
っていうことが分かるんです
確かに今我々も 都市では生きてるんです
生きてるんだけど 何か私は 足りないんですね
それを感じたい 見たい
自分にはどこまでできるんだろう というのを
確認したい
そういう想いが 私が北極に行く
一つの原動力なのかもしれません
私がその北極に行ったきっかけ というかですね
一番初めのきっかけは
今から14年くらい前になるんですけど
2000年に初めて北極に行ったんですね
その前の年の 99年の ３月で
大学を中退しました
３年通って大学やめちゃったんですね
その頃まで何にもやったこともなくて
アウトドアを 今でこそこんな冒険家 なんてやってますけど
その時までアウトドアもやったことないですし
海外旅行も行ったことないですし
普通に まあ今日ここに参加してくれている大学生の若い
ボランティアのスタッフとかいましたけども
もうみなさんと全く変わらない
20年間 21年間だったと思うんですよ
別に普通の人です
ただなんかこう
煮え切らないものがあったというか
毎日が面白くなかったんですよ
俺には何かできるんじゃないか って
ずっと思っていたんですよ
できるはずだ みたいな
若い頃って みんな誰しもあると思うんですけど
根拠のない自信 みたいなものが満々とあって
エネルギーだけはあるんですよ
でもそれをどこに使っていいか全く分からなくて
憤りというか 怒りというか
そんな状態で
大学もやめて
３月でやめて
その年の 99年の７月21日だったんですけども
偶然見ていたテレビに
冒険家の大場満郎さんという方が
北極南極歩くっていう
冒険する人がいるんですけども
テレビに出ていたんですね
トーク番組だったんですけども
北極とか南極とかの話をしていて
その番組で初めてその人のことを知ったわけです
足の指を凍傷で10本全部切っちゃってたりですとかね
白熊にテント襲われて死にそうになったとか
そんな話を色々としているわけですよ
「何だろうこの人 頭おかしいんじゃないかな」ってね
「すげえなこの人」 と思って 見てたんですけど
でもなんかやっぱり 「すげえな」 なんですよ
何か惹かれるものがあって
一生懸命テレビの中でもこう 喋っているんですよね
そしたらその番組の中で
「来年若い人を連れて 大学生くらいの若者
10人くらいを連れて
一緒に北極を歩こうと思っているんですよ」
っていうことを 喋ってたんですよ
700キロ 北極を歩く 大学生連れて
「ああ 俺もこれ行ってみたいな」って
そのテレビを見ていて
「これ行ってみたいな」って思ったんですよ
そのあと 大場さんに手紙を書いたんですね
「私も偶然テレビを見て 何にもやったことないんですけど
アウトドア経験もないし 海外旅行も行ったことないし
行けるんでしょうか」 とそんな感じの手紙を出したら
後日 返事が返ってきて
それがきっかけで 参加することになったんですね
私が22歳の時 2000年の４月から５月にかけて
カナダの北極圏の 海の上を700キロ歩くという
グループでですね そういう旅を 行いました
私にとって初めての北極 初めての海外旅行
（笑）
それ行く前に パスポートを取って
「どこ行くんですか？北極です」ってね
（笑）
まあカナダなんですけどね
カナダの北極圏になるんです
初めてのアウトドア体験
700キロ 北極歩く というのをやりました
翌年の2001年から 23の時から
じゃあ今度一人で北極行ってみようと思うようになって
23の時から今度は現地の村に
一人で通うようになって
それから毎年のように長い距離を一人で歩く
ということを 繰り返してきています
そんな 10何年をずっと繰り返してきて
今 チャレンジしようとしているのが
その 北極点無補給単独徒歩 というものなんですけども
やはり難しいんですよね 非常に
世界で今まで
その「無補給単独」というその縛り
縛りですよね　制限をかけて
北極点まで到達したのは人類史上
まだ一人しかいません
月に行った人間の方が多いですね
（笑）
そう考えるとね
月に行っている方が 何人か行ってますから
北極点はね 行けるんですよ
飛行機チャーターすれば行けるんですけども
どうやって行くか ということなんですが
非常に難しくてですね
初めは 大場さんに連れて行ってもらってから
北極点のチャレンジというのは
2012年から スタートしているんですけども
そこまでは 基本的に私はもうずっと
一人でやってきたんですね
日本にいる間に アルバイトをして半年くらい働いて
お金つくって 100万200万
たまには300万くらい
とりあえず半年寝ずに働いてつくると
それを持って北極へ行く
全部使う 帰ってくる すっからかんになってる
また働く お金作る 北極行く 全部使う
というのを10年くらいやってきたんですけど
じゃあ 次は北極点だと
もう俺も十分 経験も積んだと
スキルも もう得ただろうと
北極点ってやっぱりお金もかかるんです
色々やはり 手続き関係とかも 必要でですね
これは一人じゃ無理だな
2000万かかるんですね
北極点行くのに 飛行機のチャーターが
何度か必要になるので
チャーター料が高いんですけども
そうなった時にですね
今現在
私の仲間が 非常に増えたというか
できたんですね
例えば
私の日本の事務局を務めてくれる人間であるとか
海外との折衝をしてくれる人間であるとか
ウェブ周りの発信をしてくれる人間とかですね
そういう人間が 仲間が 集まってきてですね
良く考えると 私はそんなに
「俺 北極点やりたいから誰か手伝ってくれ！」ってね
呼びかけた覚えも あんまりないんですけども
なんか気が付いたら
手伝ってくれる人が 横にいたんですよね
多分その初めの10年間
一人でやってきた10年間というのは
私は一人でやりたいと思ってました
それは 自分がどこまでできるかって
やっぱり知りたかったんですよね
自分の領分を知りたかったというか
試したかったというか 確認したかったんです
そこまでやって
「もう北極のことだったら俺は誰にも負けん」と
でも 「お金集めってどうやったらいいんだろう」って
分からないんですね
自分に足りない部分を
仲間が今度はフォローしてくれるようになった
「根拠のない自信」っていうところから
スタートしたんですけど
やり続けていったら やはりだんだんそれは
自分の確固たる自信に 変わってきたんですね
「俺はこれはできる」 と
「俺にしかできない」っていう風に
今は思っています
大袈裟かもしれないですけど
北極のエクスペディションに関して
私は 多分日本で一番知っています
でも そんなもの誰が
必要とするかは知りませんけど（笑）
そういうことで 今やっているんですけれども
それはまた 「自分の北極でのチャレンジ」というのと
もう一つ 一昨年から始めているものがあってですね
日本での活動ですね
日本ではですね 今
いくつかやっているんですけども
夏休みに子供たちを連れて長い距離を歩く
っていうことを 始めています
一回目は一昨年に 北海道で 網走から釧路まで
160キロあるんですけど
そこを子供たち 小学生ですね
３人連れて
13日間かな キャンプしながら歩いたんですけども
去年が夏休み 第二回で
東京で 東京駅をスタートして
富士山のてっぺんまで 160キロ歩いたんですね
100マイル 160キロで
距離を設定しているんですけど
それも11日間でした
今年の夏休みにも 三回目を行う予定ですね
今年は大阪の海を 港をスタートして
大阪の街のど真ん中を通って
京都の真ん中を通過して
琵琶湖から山を越えて
福井県の日本海側まで 160キロですね
これを10日間かけて 小学生たちを連れて
今５人集まっているんですけど
一応定員６人にしているんですけども
まだ一人余裕ありますから
（笑）
６年生ですよ
そんなこともやっています
また先々はですね
やはり私は一番初め 大場さんに連れられて
北極を歩いた という経験があるので
今度は自分が 若い人を連れて
北極行きたいなっていう
思いもあるんですね
まあこれは別に 世のため人のために
何かやろうっていうわけではなくて
自分が楽しそうだから
やりたいんですよね
今でも 当時の私みたいに何かこう
「何やってるんだろうな 」ってね
煮え切らずに生きている若者は
絶対いるでしょうから
私もその気持ちは良く分かるので
そういう連中を連れて
一緒に北極なんか歩けたらいいなと 思っています
冒険っていうのは
一番大事なのは 「主体性」 だと思うんですね
「自分に主体を持つこと」です
主体を自分に持って
自分の行動をまず信じることですね
信じて 好奇心を持って
試行錯誤を繰り返すこと
それが 「冒険」 だと思ってます
なので 冒険って別に
北極であるとか アマゾン川であるとか
そんな遠く離れた僻地でしか
行えないものではなくて
日常生活 みんな冒険なわけですね
自分がこの踏む出す一歩っていうのは
誰の 判断の 主体の一歩なのか
それは私は自分の主体でありたいと
常に思ってますし
北極で言えば 自分の主体で判断して
一歩を踏み出さないと危険である という
そういう教訓があるんですね
人の判断で踏み出すと 死ぬんです
そこが危険なのか そうではないのか
行けるのか行けないのか って判断できるのは
現場では自分しかいないので
周り誰もいないですから
常に判断の主体は 自分に置かなければいけない
それは北極であろうが 都市であろうが
変わらない話なのかな と思っています
私は 「主体的に 能動的に生きること」
それが冒険だと思って
これからも そういう風に生きながら
自分の冒険をしつつ
今まで得てきた経験を 社会に
どう還元できるかなっていうことも
日本に帰ってきてから テーマに
今後も 冒険をしていきたいと思っています
今日はありがとうございました！
（拍手）